what's up everyone we are at Harvard
Medical School with dr. joel salinas hi
thank you for joining us on the show
thanks for the invitation this is gonna
be a lot of fun Joelle is a assistant
professor of no neurology at Harvard
Medical School also a neurologist at the
Massachusetts General Hospital
Department of Neurology and a
neurologist of the McCants Center for
brain health along with being the author
of mirror-touch and he's a superhero
movie buff he loves comics he's obsessed
with cheese in nature so this is gonna
be a lot of fun let's dive right in all
right do it so how did you know that you
wanted to get into Neurology and help
people let's see I think we're gonna
growing up I always had the sense it was
something really different or odd about
me and I just kind of talked up being
this like really weird kid and I think
one of the things that came along with
it just was this really being observant
of the people around me and
understanding like how and why they were
doing what they were doing and through
school I found that I just really love
science and I just saw out like that was
the thing that really tied everything
together was just human behavior and an
undergrad at Cornell I studied biology
and sociology I did research in the
Amazon studying why people decided to
continue to drink contaminated water and
eat contaminated fish I was like
fascinated about how all this came
together and and also seeing how how
helping other people just felt so
amazing for a number of different
reasons and that kind of got me into
medicine and then I still remember the
specific lecture that looks like just
blew my mind open it was this one
lecture talking about the split brain it
was just like a regular didactic session
and I don't through media with the split
brain but essentially back in the day
one of the things that they would do to
treat seizure was a surgery called
a corpus callosotomy so essentially
you've got your two hemispheres of the
brain left and right and there's there's
kind of wiring that connects the two
hemispheres and so if someone has a
seizure on one of those it can cross to
the other side
and people didn't have good treatments
for seizures what they would do is just
cut the connection so they wouldn't get
the seizures crossing over the other
side but was this really fascinating is
these people maybe their seizures were a
little bit better but then they were
acting a little funny and one of the
ways that they were acting a little
funny was they might start kind of
buttoning up their shirt but then their
right hand might be unbuttoning the
shirt while they were butting with their
left or they they the brain you know the
a lot of language is found on the left
side of the brain and the right has a
lot of kind of visual spatial kind of
attention function and they were finding
that it was this split in the brain
essentially turned people into two
people within a single body and that
just I blew my mind it's the idea that
there are consciousness who we are could
be divided into smaller parts I just say
felt like it just felt right it was just
I'm a guy got goose bumps
so that that was like I want to work
with the motherboard of reality and
being in Neurology lets me to treat
patients you know with this with the
whole nervous system which is I think
about having impact on someone's life
and what more impact and you have then
helping to treat someone's sense of
reality their whole universe you you
list all these amazingly fascinating
social and behavioral aspects of the way
that our mind perceives reality as well
as the way that our that our brain can
be altered and if our brain gets altered
in these ways it changes our behavior
and it's so interesting to observe
reality and be able to to pluck away at
how things actually work how humans
actually work and how you can help
people along the way yeah and all right
so for these years what would have been
some of these coolest things that you've
been uncovering that you
we've been enjoying well I think you
know in addition to becoming like a like
a physician like learning this like
medicine and becoming kind of like a
mechanic of the body has been just like
really eye-opening but specifically in
Neurology I think one of the things that
really there really was eye-opening was
just seeing just how many differences
there are in its the put in human
presentation how every little experience
that we have every kind of past it kind
of environment that we've been in helps
to shape our brain and that's in
addition to like every every gene
everything that's going on in our body
like all these things come together to
create a person at that moment and
that's constantly changing yeah so say
seeing patients who have all sorts of
all sorts of diseases and things from
stroke to Alzheimer's disease to
autistic kind of spectrum disorders to
the degree where they're kind of
impaired in their day to day functioning
to people who had spinal cord injuries
to peripheral nerve injuries like all
these different things really shape a
person's life and their experience of of
the world around them yeah and just
seeing how I don't want to say that it's
fragile I want to say that it's
resilient how resilient could have human
perception of us and just how broad that
experience can be and how one person's
reality can be completely different and
mutually exclusive of another person's
reality just totally irreconcilable and
they can be sitting right next to you
yeah exactly
I mean one of one of the things that one
of the statements that I've heard that
really kind of played at home for me was
just this idea that all you will ever
know is the state of your own nervous
system yeah which is just incredible
right
it ends beautiful in so many different
ways that you could definitely like see
that as like very depressing right like
the human condition means that we're all
kind of this organ locked away in this
dark skull we're all just trying to
figure it out but at the same time I
think it just opens up just so many
opportunities that we can connect with
each other and how we can all kind of
come together to create this larger more
cohesive
thinlits just amazing yeah yeah we talk
a lot about the hundred billion people
that have lived and died to build this
beautiful world that we live in today
and how though that was all whatever a
hundred billion different brains locked
inside of skulls but then somehow
through their subjective personal
experiences they all also managed to
collaborate collectively to build the
hospitals and the schools and the
economies and the political systems and
the ubiquity and water and food and
energy and so once we get to a point of
understanding that ok we are in
different vehicles right now but we are
also part of this greater intelligence
exactly exactly and you know as even as
we're interacting right now our brain
will not be the same at the end of this
conversation exactly so I'm shaping your
brain you're shaping my brain the whole
environment keeping my brain I love this
idea that the brain
a better metaphor than just thinking of
the brain as as a computer would be to
think of it as an analogy would be to
think of it as as a liquid that it we
evolved so that way our brain can fit
into any environment like we're born
yeah that's with all of the blueprints
and kind of the substance to adapt to
any environment because you could be
plopped into a different country
tomorrow and you would be able to adapt
you'd figure out how to get water how to
get food how to learn the language how
to learn the culture how to play the
music absolutely I mean and when we were
and when our brain is at its most
plastic mean that it's most kind of open
to making new connections is when we're
like born yeah and it's just incredible
to see how much we can learn in such a
short period of time and how those
things that we learn very early really
do have an impact on the trajectory of
our lives so there's some beautiful work
done looking at language development and
this is it's not just language is that
everything but the studies looking at
how kids learn
learn language so for example kids very
very early in a household that speaks
only English for example can still pick
up minor differences in other languages
so in this one study they have a kid
kind of popped in the mom flap and
there's a researcher in front of them
and the researcher is external little
toy and while they're being shown this
little toy there's a recording being
played that plays either ba this R da or
da so dot or dot uu it's hard to tell
the difference yeah it's it they're two
different common Hindi syllables so dot
and dot and what they kind of train the
baby to do is as they're playing da da
da da at some point it changes to da and
when that happens they put they have
like a little bunny in the corner that
lights up and plays the drums and so the
kid learns that whenever there's a
change to look to the bunny Wow and so
you you you know that the kid has
learned this because once they change
even when the bunny is not lit up
they're looking for the bunny to light
up there are cuteness and sensitivity is
increasing so much right right
and now after about 10 months old if you
to do that with with another baby also
kind of only in an english-speaking
household they wouldn't be able to pick
up that difference anymore you could
play his bow or da and they wouldn't
look tor the bunny anymore and you can
see that also in languages like Spanish
where was fun go I see yeah so the
difference between ba and var is
something that people who speak only
Spanish can't pick up on as easily as
people who speak English for example or
the difference between LA and uh in
Japanese in the Japanese speaking
household the L sound and the R sound
are kind of converged somehow but these
are this is just how our brain shapes
and some of these pieces really come
together and influence the rest of your
life and that's not just for language
but also you know what you perceive as
being like affection or good or not good
or just like what you perceive as
as being associated with you I mean even
I mean think of this how the senses kind
of form our first sense as we develop is
touch in the womb at about six months
you can begin to see brain activity that
I step touch stimuli and how did we
manage to map our child I know it's kind
of crazy it's a it's a it's a VOC
potential work so just looking to see if
there's kind of a change in brain waves
and that or it's kind of crazy crazy
work but that is it's also the first
sense to mature too and our our skin is
here's like that one of the mind-blowing
things so if you think about and that's
really interesting footage of kind of
development that came out recently so
right we started sick a sperm and egg
and then we're this like this like cell
that begins to divide and divide and
divide a divided divided until looks
like a raspberry and then it continues
turns into like different layers so we
have this thing called endoderm mesoderm
and ectoderm which are kind of like
three put a primordial kind of layers
that turn into like all these other
organs so ectoderm is is your skin right
that's what your skin comes from but
what else who comes from ectoderm your
whole nervous system hmm I mean that's
amazing right so our we kind of fold
into the second person that we're a lot
of the things that you see on the skin
you can also see in the brain aha yeah
it's but especially the what are they
called the the neural tube formation the
tube formation yeah what's that if would
there's another word for it with us that
that where they fold down the folds in
the brain what are those called again so
kind or so say suicide yeah so what is a
sulcus and then and then and so then
that can also be visible maybe on your
on the click on these crevasses on on
your skin apparently the only reason why
we have such distinct and acute levels
of touch is because of these ridges on
our skin if it was all flat we wouldn't
have this distinct touch
there's a lot of surface area for nerve
endings which can happen a ton and I
think the the point that you make is is
really important that that you know the
vastness of the minut minut difference
is you can see on someone's skin are
actually not that different from the
vastness of the number of differences
that we can have brain to brain yeah
from the level of individual cells in
the brain to how those cells come
together I think one thing that people
often forget about in the brain is that
it's not just neurons which typically
kind of get all the attention but
there's also the cells that kind of
create the insulation around the
connections there's also support there's
the kind of solving system I mean like
astrocytes for example are involved and
kind of I thought of it as the glue but
the way that astrocytes work can
actually influence how neurons work too
which adds a whole other massive layer
of computation to how the brain works
okay I gotta unpack a couple things okay
one of the things that I want to unpack
is how the senses can connect to each
other of course
yeah which is a lot of your work but
also maybe before we get there we talked
about a child you said in the womb is
experiencing touch as a first set yeah
and then when do we typically experience
vision as a sense when do we start
getting into the other senses and also
how does this affect our development as
we were talking about language and the
importance of language for children when
they're very young
seeing ASEA chair as well as a chair
right as well as a stool or whatever you
want to call Chris Lowe there's so many
words for it across different languages
and what does that do to be able to
perceive something in like six different
languages yeah and you can maybe that
we've heard a couple times on the show
that in in Hindi there might be a couple
dozen ways to say something of there's
only one way to say in
yeah yeah yeah I think what you're
hitting on is this continent is the
concept of concepts so as your brain is
experiencing the world even through
through development I mean in
development really more than anything it
has to the key things with development
is timing and also how sensitive it is
to kind of kind of adapting or kind of
taking in the information making those
connections but a concept can involve a
network of all these different neurons
that are firing all these different
cells that are coming together so for
example we can look at a chair right and
your brain when you're born may actually
see a blob that has no no concept to it
but as you're growing up you're learning
like like someone's teaching you this is
called a chair we sit in a chair and as
you is you're growing up you're also
like oh yeah chairs can be hard they can
be made of wood or metal and that begins
to form this concept of chair which has
this vast network of color wood the
sound that ties to to the concept of
this as chair chair to your all your
past memories of having been in a chair
or falling out of a chair or haven't I
think had a very comfortable experience
in the chair I think one of the older
models of how we thought about the brain
was that the senses are kind of unitary
that they're kind of in their individual
modules and they kind of kind of connect
with each other a little bit in between
and and they all have very specific
places in the brain where that can only
be and I think what we've learned is
that things are much much more flexible
you know your your your brain can have a
vision area just about really anywhere
and it just happens to be in the back
part of the brain because anatomically
that's it just connected to the optic
nerves of the eyes where it's getting a
lot of that information but if you were
to have like an injury or he's a great
example is on people they can Tory's
back here too right oh Factory is
actually right in the front legs up here
yeah yeah so frontal lobe is here so if
I were to just kind of like point like
right in there there's like a plate that
they have it's like a like a cheese
grater kind of plate where
kind of neurons could have come out and
taken that information we were the cool
things about welfare right here through
the nose yeah Mel
so the olfactory nerves are the only
part of your brain that are exposed to
the air oh that is cool
isn't that crazy exposed to the actual
air ivory swen I recently learned a
couple months ago that the whole
gastrointestinal tract is like you know
exposed I guess to the air from this
side and then now you're yeah yeah rest
easy so so the nerve is our because
that's that's how you take the particle
from the air and then smell whether or
not the food is good or not yeah there's
really that for survival different types
of basically these nerve cells use a
factory nerve cells that respond to
different chemicals in the air you can
have however many that respond to
specific families of chemicals and it
just happens to go right into the
frontal lobe right in the front part of
the brain then that kind of information
goes to the rest of the brain and all
these different senses are actually
highly highly highly connected and
integrated much more than we thought in
the past so any concept any smell any
sound has a lot of a lot of these other
senses so for example a smell can
actually have color and texture and all
these other senses tied to it usually
below the level of consciousness you
don't know that it's going on but it's a
concept that you've developed but in
there's these people with synesthesia
that are usually consciously aware of
how their senses can be highly highly
connected so would it be maybe something
like smelling the food that you're about
to eat and maybe then knowing what color
that food is and then seeing a little
bit those colors being a little bit more
bright yeah whatever whatever that
concept is for example if you were to
smell let's say you were to smell like
baby powder right if your concept is
heavily kind of grounded into this
button you're seeing babies yeah
be white exactly people with synesthesia
it can be a little quicker than that so
for me baby powder the smell of baby
parts very specifically is like a light
blue color and it's one of the reasons
why people with synesthesia can actually
can tell the difference between
different senses more so than people
without synesthesia so there's one
interesting City that was done looking
at olfactory color or smell color
synesthesia and they found that that
people who had smell color synesthesia
were much more attuned to not just
identifying smells but also telling
difference between two different smells
it was one of the reasons why someone
with with kind of smell collusion it
sees it might actually be a really good
somali a the really good wine tasters
yeah there's one guy named Jamie Smith
he's out in out in the West he's been
kind of named by food and wine as like
one of the world's best Somalis more
than once and he has kind of this like
tea smell kind of color synesthesia and
you can likely also train that in
yourself or in a child over time to get
them like you said with this experiment
with the bunny in the corner yeah I
think to a degree we can train a lot of
these different experiences and BR our
brain again is so plastic I wonder what
would happen if you really trained a
child across the senses very strongly to
have synesthesia across senses what
would that person end up looking like it
depends it depends so part of it is
biology and the other part is the
environment or like that training or the
experience so people with synesthesia
typically also have a different biology
so people with synesthesia are often
genetically different and their brains
look and work differently compared to
other people and work done by Julie
similar on the you
looking at kind of development in
synesthesia well actually I'll take a
step back here and say that you're right
in that just about everybody has
synesthesia up until about h2 hmm
and then it typically goes away as our
brains begin to do this process called
pruning so we're cutting wise so yeah
cutting out excess connections because
your brain wants to save energy it wants
to be very efficient and so pruning is
essentially like getting rid of roads to
make room for highways and that highway
might be like your mom's name and your
dad's name and how to get to the
bathroom from your reading or or like on
literacy yeah yeah so when you know when
we're babies we're all like hyper hyper
connected but these people with
synesthesia it seems like they may not
be pruning as much or their brains may
be making more connections so I really
liked your analogy about getting rid of
roads for highway right right yeah and
so that people with synesthesia may have
these kind of quirky connections that
don't make sense to a lot of people but
these connections just like everybody
else will typically form maximally
during the early developmental period of
life so kids will typically develop
their synesthetic associations the most
kind of around ages four all the way up
to like each ten it usually happening
until like I mean very very early when
really fascinating study that was done
by David Eagleman looking at I love
David II yeah so he he had a website
where people could kind of like plug in
their synesthetic associations and one
of those was their number letter color
association so that's called
grapheme-color synesthesia where people
will have a very very reliable
consistent and very vivid color tied to
every single letter or number
uh-huh and Wow so for example like for
me the word cat letter C is black letter
a is red and letter T is red orange even
though it's bite you the whole thing may
be written in black from
like there's also kind of an additional
color layered on top yeah where C is
black a is red T is red orange all
together it's kind of that's a cloud of
like black and red and orange yeah yeah
and so for people who who he collected
this like large large number of
associations of people and they found
that there were some kind of
similarities between people so one
similarity is that high frequency
letters are typically brighter hmm so he
bowels for sure for brighter the letter
A typically was a bright red low
frequency letters or dark gray or X
exactly or typically like a black kind
of a color yeah but then there's just
one group of people that had a lot of
similarities in their alphabet and the
color kind of alphabet associations and
they weren't sure why so they they tried
it they dug into it a little bit more
and they saw that they were all around
the same age overall and so they they
took it in to even further and they said
that they're all around about 4 to 6
years old in the early eighties which is
around the same time that fisher-price
released a set of alphabet magnets in
the fridge right right and so a lot of
those magnets though their colors
titleist anaesthetic associations Oh
interesting
yeah that's crazy yeah I mean I grew up
with those magnets and one of my
favorite kind of went some of my
favorite magnets are the ones that tie
to my colors yeah oh that's so and and
even then with the way that kids learn
literacy if the Coletta's are colored
whatever color they are then that will
tie them in sin aesthetically over time
I wonder if there's a way to maximize
their potential or outcomes by having
the color the letters be certain colors
well I think there's there's a lot of
work still being done
terms of how how synesthesia can inform
education and learning and one of those
ways that I think is is important to
notice is that really emphasizing an
individual learning style and how they
perceive the world can actually make a
big difference so as an example of that
one other form this is Ricky we're gonna
keep going down layers of the rabbit
hole this is another layer down the
rabbit hole so one of the many forms of
synesthesia that I have is known as
ordinal linguistic personification olp
which is one that you can see in the you
know people have synesthesia so or no
linguistic or linguistic personification
so ordinal is a quarter linguistic is
language percent if occation is like
personalities and characteristics so
just based off of that does have
anything do zip slaw maybe that even the
Pareto principle applies to our language
oh yeah yeah I think it I think it
really does so like from for myself and
people who have our LP numbers and
letters have personality traits tied to
them too it's for me it's especially
like my numbers don't just have colors
they're like people too so like the
number two is like red with a little bit
of violet but it's also a very maternal
very feminine kind of
number of fierce three is like a dark
purple indigo color but also very humble
it doesn't really like let on to others
I comments to potential it could say
it's really details like people and and
this is part of this like process of
kind of like the brain kind of making
music interesting and weird connection
so you can think of in terms of learning
you imagine two plus two right for if
two plus two is a quantity for you it
makes sense it's four but what if - is
this like fierce feminine number if you
had two plus two what does that mean
yeah it's just a crowd of fierce women
in numbers it doesn't make sense that
they would turn into for a blue for
that's friendly and passive that's a
common issue in the arithmetic with
people who have olp and if and if you
are someone teaching math and you knew
that you'd be able to tailor to maybe
think about that don't think about the
number two as a person think of it as
like two objects sure apples to apples
for apples yeah yeah Wow this is so
awesome
okay huh this is so interesting okay how
about how about with me when I listen to
someone speak and this will pick you
back a little on the Pareto principle
and sifts law but we have the word the
or and or of or which or to these words
that are filler words between the main
words those words don't really create a
spark for me in no aching since they
don't worry to spark because they said
so often well not a very six words we
say is a dog yeah so I almost even tune
out sometimes the word ah and I'm tuning
in for your keywords yeah so maybe when
you say a word like epistemology for me
that categorizes you or ontology right
that categorizes ya into a category of
thought of like oh you're like analyzing
the nature of being yeah to a certain
degree already then you at least know
that
or when you do talk about maybe the word
empathy and compassion and yeah at least
you're thinking about it so maybe that
can be a more friendly word for me like
those words are more friendly maybe
they're more pink and purple II and then
Epis Tamaki and ontology or maybe a
little bit more green in nature yeah we
yeah it's a you're exactly I think
you're hitting on - kind of big steers
of ideas so one is a concept of salience
essentially and like me being tied to
think this the sensory kind of bundle
that's being provided so any word can
lose meaning or salience when repeated
enough yeah so for example let's say
like the word and like bottle bottle
bottle bottle bottle bottle bottle
bottle you say it enough times an
adventure you're like that's like an
alien word it doesn't make sense anymore
it's like whoa
and that's when you when you losing that
that concept that ties around around it
and now the it is you that as you kind
of highlighted like articles
conjunctions can have some of that too
so that feeling where it may not have
that much salience tied to them but
they're still it kind of involved in the
process below the surface it's just not
important enough that your that your
body is saying gooo pay attention to
that or oh these are things to feel
around here yeah now the other kind of
big idea here is one model for nernst
like the book being about how the brain
works is called predictive coding they
size into another kind of like big model
of the free energy principle but
essentially predictive coding is all
about
your brain is this organ that is there
not
not to its it's there to predict the
future
first and foremost and so the whole idea
behind memories is not that memories are
particularly nice but that memories help
to get away from predators help you to
understand it like this this thing here
it's gonna support it's gonna support
you yeah exactly and if something
happens that you don't expect your brain
is in a really hone in on that so that
way you learn hey this can happen yeah
so that's one of the things that may
viable mechanism yeah exactly and
there's one of the things that makes
that magic tricks so cool right or
surprises so awesome or awe so so
amazing is that your your brain will
suddenly trigger this physical response
through hormones through increasing your
heart rate and your blood pressure and
and kind of releasing glucose and core
all these things that kind of relate to
that we could relate to like being
aroused being alert when something
doesn't match the prediction that we
that we make and so conjunctions and
articles as you were saying like the
know of it and your brain is just like
yeah whatever like keep going like this
is a smooth but if you get a word that
you didn't expect yeah exactly exactly
and you can do that with with any
predictive pattern so like um like a I
mean this is one of the reasons why
we're just like very story driven
species we find patterns and random
things that's called like the Ramsey
principle where you look up at the sky
and you'll see like a crab or a jog or a
horse even though it's a randomly
derivative Lee randomly distributed or
if you were to kind of like all the
alphabet soups and the series we will
find the pattern and we'll create a
story in my chip will create a whole
story as to why that's significant
in Sao posted on reddit and get 10,000
uploads yeah that's right
or even like music is another kind of
beautiful example of that is that
there's chord progressions that we're
we've been like learned essentially and
there may be some genetic component to
that as well cuz people across various
cultures can have similar
predictions of what the next kind of
note should be but a very programmed
thing so I think of like Beethoven like
Benin and and you're already hearing but
what if we were here like Benin and uh
yeah great sick of like a weird feeling
yeah yeah cuz that's a predictive error
happy birthday to me yeah and that's
that's comedy
yeah right about comedy people into
their predictive mechanism and all of a
sudden you're like nope exactly exactly
internet creates it's like this physical
sensation that can be pleasurable it can
be painful it can be a cop it can be
like really alert yeah I feel like Bo
Burnham did that decently well he would
take you into the predictive and then he
would just go yeah if you look at a lot
of comedy at the heart of it is this
idea we create a world you create a set
of expectations and then we just rock
that expectation yeah that's really
interesting okay Ben's good thrillers
good movies I mean that's at the core of
it yeah
all right let's come on our honor on our
end of closing there's so much to talk
about and I'm I'm excited to continue
the conversation we'll definitely have
some more parts to this once we get out
here more you come out there more to
stuff how about we talk about overall
brain health mm-hmm yeah yeah teach us
about what you've been uncovering yeah
so a lot of the work that we're doing at
the Macan Center for brain health at
Mass General is thinking about the brain
from more positive health oriented kind
of point of view so right now the way
that that health care typically works is
I think happens we fix it right yeah why
not think about preventing that bad
thing from happening in the first place
and so we're we are applying that model
and like bringing people in and becoming
kind of like a primary care doctor for
the brain so we figure out what are your
risk factors
what are your protective factors and how
we can we tune things up so that way
your brain can be as healthy as possible
for as long as possible and so that can
mean just one is it understanding all
that we know about in terms of evidence
is available from public health research
from epidemiology and applying it very
practically to the appropriate level of
evidence that's there so that can mean
saying all right how much are you
exercising because exercise really does
it it has it plays a very important role
in the health of your brain by reducing
so many different risk factors I think
it's partly you know getting your heart
beating and your blood vessels gonna be
healthier but also it's like something
that you're learning it is it is
actually stimulating the brain so like
taking dance for example is something
that we recommend often because it's got
a combination of the exercise it's got a
the learning right and it's also got the
socialization aspect of it and that's
another end of kind of the research I do
is looking at how social relationships
you know how we connect with people does
influence our brains health it can be
very positive it can also be harmful to
and so is being better armed with this
information help us live live more
fulfilling more like healthier lives you
can be your pick the best version of
yourself as possible and why not take it
from the standpoint of the brain is the
brain and your body you're bringing your
body here just so so linked together
yeah
that that really addressing that can
really go a long way
I like how you recommended dance yeah
because that totally makes sense you're
both doing some socialization having to
work with like other men and women you
have to do the series of steps with your
dancing you have to get into a set of
flow and you also doing the physical
exercise another good one is what we've
been learning with Adam GaSe Ellie's lab
and neuro scape and being able to
prescribe videogames for ADHD for
attention for working memory for all
these different aspects of life and so
you know we're thinking instead of
peaking cognition at 23 and then it's
just the slow deep I'm well why not
figure out ways to keep cognition even
higher over time and all of a sudden you
can be even more creative when you're 50
years old cuz you've been playing with
these different tools that we've built
that that help maximize your minds
ability to to exercise restoring new
thoughts I'm storing more thoughts at a
time in your mind yeah absolutely at the
heart of our mission is its what I mean
there's many different models for why
these healthy things can actually be
healthy and one of them is this idea of
cognitive reserve which is as you're
making new connections new roads you
have more left over so that way if you
do develop a disease losing a couple of
them you still have a connection that
you can make there I mean some of the
work that has been done in terms of
social relationships is also been echoed
in some of my own work is people who are
more socially integrated you know if you
think of it as a mentally stimulating
activity at the end of their life if you
look at their brains no matter how much
kind of Alzheimer's related disease they
have in their brain the people who are
most socially integrated or at least
likely to have symptoms so they they
could have had a lot of Alzheimer's
disease in their brain but you wouldn't
have known it because they had a lot of
these excess connections most likely and
at the same time this uh you know video
games you brought up I think that's a
really important example because I think
people who who want to get big brain
training games and things like that I
think the key to know about that is it's
not about the game itself it's that it's
challenging
he said it's creating new connections
yes so it could be you know it could be
crossword puzzles Sudoku but once you
get kind of good at it it loses its
effect so you want to switch to
something else or keep it keep it as
challenging as possible and there's a
certain peak state of chat of challenge
that you want to get from the game but
also you don't want to be challenged so
much that you fail all the time so
there's this really yeah and as you get
better the challenge level increases
okay so brain health is obviously
crucial I thought what you were
describing a second ago was really
interesting so so cognitive reserve is
then me having a couple of these
connections and as maybe over time they
prune a lot of the roads go away and
then there's cognitive reservists having
at least one or couple of these roads
left so that way I still at least can
access this memory of this information
I'm more connected your brains kind of
cell networks are the more likely you'll
still get to the action or the memory or
the concept that was there before
because you can imagine as each neurons
being plucked or each connections being
plucked there's um there's the risk that
you were kind of cut cut off a lot of
them and you lose a memory you lose an
experience using name for something yeah
and so the idea is connect connect away
make as many connections as you can and
then very kind of directed really
challenging ways like really strong
connections to so that way even if you
lose a couple it's like no big you heard
it here you heard it here be
multidisciplinary
be Polymathic learn about lots of
different things and then you'll get
these these complex diverse connections
in your mind about the way that reality
works learning is cool yeah learnings
cool learning fun
oh that's a good point so then there's
the point of understanding how reality
works like oh how this grass how well
that let's let's go to this example so
for example this the grass right the
grass is is getting energy from the star
and then growing and energy from the
soil and growing and water and growing
so these things come together and there
can be one person's reality is that
that's how it works
and the other person's reality can just
be like oh it's just green stuff on the
ground and that's what I know about it
and that's it so there's different
different realities about about that so
yeah how how do we balance you'll know
something else yeah yeah really
disintegrates a lot of those concepts or
I mean the you yeah you you get a lot of
information that's crossing connecting
ways they would normally connect and so
that's like reality or concepts are
suddenly blur yeah but the I the idea
that um there are physical principles in
the world that are consistent but our
perception of it or how we talk about it
ties to probabilities you know science
is all about under getting uncertainty
to be a little less uncertain yes
because getting to 100% certainty is
highly highly highly improbable like a
point line or a plane and geometry like
there undefined for a reason is because
you can only get so much before your
tools are unable to really measure those
things and so you know there's a there's
there's that element of it but there's
also kind of a social reality so you and
I can look at this and agree that it's a
chair because you and I have had similar
experiences or similar environments or
similar enough that we can both
acknowledge that this is a chair but
there's the finer grain kind of
experiences the unit of the chair so
that this has a different charge for you
than it does yeah for me yeah you
actly maybe I was an arborist in the
past life right no and I'm like no I'm
like I don't know about these wooden
chairs I prefer the metal one yeah maybe
maybe I fell out of a chair like this so
when I see this I'm like good is not
good yes yes all right how about we
touch on a little bit on the magic
mushroom side of things
yeah go ahead it's okay
well because what we thought what we
were talking about earlier I thought was
really good which is that synesthesia
creates this blend of senses but then
also we have the mind-altering
substances LSD psilocybin 5mb DMT
there's so many of these different even
cannabis is a mind-altering alcohol is
but what how do they impact the way that
our senses get blended and then that's
almost they get they come in for the
short term just like a couple hours of
the sense blending and then there's also
the effect on the neurology of the
serotonin 2a receptor and then that is
this overwhelmingly interest in maybe in
reality and in all these different
senses so yeah unpack this for us a bit
so the idea of like hallucinations and
hallucinogens a part of it is kind of
really getting at this mechanism of
predictive coding so like guessing right
so your brain is constantly making
guesses about the world like I'm
guessing that I'm gonna be in this chair
another second yes that I want to
suddenly disappear
yes I'm guessing that like a dragon will
not appear out of here but it might rain
but but it might rain exactly and so
with these loosen engines or substances
that are getting at the basic mechanisms
of these cells so it is an example like
LSD specifically affects the serotonin
type 2a receptors which has actually
been implicated in in synesthesia as
well as one of the many potential ways
that synesthesia can develop but you can
imagine that if you are making a lot of
excess connections
and or Endor you're making it harder for
your brain to filter out guesses
you're just making all sorts of guesses
we're even like I'm interesting so like
for example if I'm looking at this grass
right here
I might suddenly start to make patterns
where there isn't a pattern so like I
can start to see like a person's face or
like this cloud is like not just looking
like a rabbit it's a rabbit that's
talking to me because your brain is
making like wild goose chase type of
guesses about the world around you it's
like too many for your for your for your
brain to be able to filter out like what
makes sense and what doesn't and
typically Occam's razor is the best
solution which is that the simplest
solution I usually write it's probably
just a bunch of yes I mean one of the
speculations as to why some of these
hallucinogens can actually be
potentially helpful in kind of mood
disorders and things like that is that
at the heart of some of these disorders
is actually a kind of an error in
predictions so one researcher dr. Lisa
filmin Barrett who does a lot of work on
emotions at what emotions where they are
a lot of concepts but a one way that she
can efrain's the idea of like anxiety
and depression as an example is but
someone with anxiety might be someone
who just makes a lot of predictions
about what's gonna happen so for example
if they hear like a rustling you know in
a bush it's not just the wind
potentially it could be like a bear or
say we do tiger or a snake and all those
predictions relate to like danger and
harm and threat and just thinking about
that harm might as well be real harm
because your your your your brain you
know it's this mechanism that's creating
simulations the simulations are very
very real in your brain yeah someone
who's depressed may have a metabolic
disorder that also makes it really hard
to step out of a prediction so you might
have a loop of like something very
traumatic that's happened in your past
so you're constantly making predicting
that the world is the worst the world is
awful or like me moving will have zero
impact on a good thing in the wind
yeah so the idea behind you know or some
of the speculation around how Huson it
might be helpful is that because there's
so many guesses it kind of resets the
whole system yeah so that way you can
make new predictions yes or kind of
challenge old predictions that you had I
mean so interesting you might not even
need to use a hallucinogen to be able to
do some of this I mean curiosity yeah is
a really important skill which is you
know just asking questions about you
know how likely is that there's our
saber-toothed tiger in a bush well let
me think about when you look at your
watch you finally go what the [ __ ] is
time exactly or it's like if you're yeah
you're you're running late for something
it's like Oh what does that really mean
yeah am I gonna die no am I being li am
I gonna get cancer no so why would I be
pissed yeah exactly and I think just
having a better sense of your brain like
gonna just this thing that we're all
born with really helps just be a more
chill yeah but then we get into the
conversation that Ron brought up which i
think is going to be talked about a lot
more on this on the on the show over
time because it's so difficult to
understand who's subjective realities
overlap to understand the world
objectively because if we do come up
with a subjective seven and a half
billion people say that the earth orbits
the star okay great we're set that's
done it's around Earth okay great
it's a collaborative approach and if you
think about like a big way that people
interact kind of like the way that brain
cells interact yeah if you have the vast
majority of the brain cells saying that
like so you know this is a chair then
you're gonna say that it's a chair if
the vast majority of people believe that
the earth is round
you could you could decide to challenge
it but also acknowledge that there's
probably something there's probably a
lot to that understanding that that this
is if there's it's highly highly highly
highly highly certain that the earth is
right exactly yeah
you know they understand that objective
well I think a big part of what you're
alluding each of these words these are
concepts right in these concepts are
part of larger networks and these
networks relate to salience to valence
or like importance but also these
physical sensations identity as well
like who you are
if someone's attacking a concept that
you identify as yourself it might as
well be like they're punching you or
attacking you and so a lot of work
that's being done inside psychology
looks at things like what's called
effect or mood but like memories thought
these concepts are tied to physical
experiences and so I think coming at
someone in a way that's threatening is
not gonna create a bridge right so I
mean one one thing that I think is
important to note is if you want to if
you want to make friends you have to be
a friend first right if you want to make
connections with somebody else you have
to let them know that it's okay to make
a connection that can mean finding areas
where you agree like we we are human I
mean you started the most fundamental
level we are human yeah you were a child
once yeah I was a child once too we both
speak this language we spokes because
they have hard slowly building that up
creates more connections between the two
of you and this is kind of this whole
other area of the brain the more you're
open to relating to the other person
seeing them as that as though they are
part of you or that you're at they are
as they are you the more likely you are
to have positive feelings towards them
to be empathetic to have similar
sensations to be compassionate
to wish them well and to be kinder to
them to actually take actions that will
be there to relieve suffering and to be
good towards them and you can imagine
that helping people to kind of agree on
something that you might see
fundamentally like how can you how could
you believe that coming at them from
that from that starting point is
unlikely to work yeah because you are
just as crazy to them as they are to you
I love how you tied it back into mirror
neurons as well is that when you do see
somebody just know that you're both
human first of all you're both speaking
the same language you both have hearts
at least if you start with these very
basic bear level points then at least
you're not going to immediately try and
create a cut like between them that you
believe something that I don't believe
that's it we're not good anymore yeah
there's some really great work on
specifically looking at that concept
using like virtual reality and even like
this basic kind of good with a call kind
of entrainment type of task but
essentially it's in this virtual reality
example if you are enter into a virtual
reality world where you look like
someone that doesn't look like how you
physically look afterwards you're more
likely to have positive thoughts and
associations that person so it's like
imagine I'm a I'm a younger white woman
in this virtual world though I'm an
older black man I'm looking at myself in
this mirror as this older black man
afterwards I'm more likely to have
positive thoughts towards yeah this out
correct that's a very good one I like
that one so looking in a mirror in VR
and seeing something that's not you and
being like oh that's what I would look
like if I was an Asian man or if I was a
black woman and because you begin to
identify that type of person as is you
exactly which is exactly we were talking
about and that builds up empathy builds
up compassion and I think you'll
eventually get us to what Ron was
talking about which is a greater
collective understanding for how to move
forward in society okay joy let's ask
you a quick question about we have these
simulation questions that we like to ask
and this has been one that we talk about
a lot and so we like to press people
about it to see what their
sar but you've really piggy backs on the
last question well but although the
Pinker argument is true that everybody
slowly going up in terms of
socioeconomic status across the world
technology is kind of exacerbating
wealth inequality for the super super
rich what do you think we're gonna do
about that gap of wealth and equality
how do we work together across the world
in this globalized world how do we
collaborate across board yes yeah I
think one element of it is kind of ties
into this mirror touch or mirroring
system kind of elements of being
empathetic compassionate that really
seeing others as as being similar to
yourself so that way you're able to take
actions so that way you're thinking of
everyone's welfare so I think that's one
one big bucket which to me I think is an
important one I mean could you imagine
what the world would look like if you
didn't just think about what it's like
to be in somebody else's shoes but also
feel what it's like to be in their shoes
yeah
so then reason through their experience
and come at it from a place that's more
compassionate and kinder and also truer
and more enduring another element of it
I think even more practically is
actually something that will be released
pretty soon by Andrew McAfee where he
really talked about this concept of
dematerialization yes which i think is a
isn't is a really important concept to
remember yeah which is as technology
advances things get smaller this things
get smaller they're likely to require
less resources and create less waste yes
which makes it easier and things get
cheaper to us it makes it easier to to
distribute some of these some of these
capacities and capabilities across the
population it can help with overall
development of the world and also has a
very strong and important environmental
impact yeah another huge right exactly
it doesn't preclude you from having it
because it's digital now and
the amount of waste that the Peter
Diamandis wrote about it as well as
we're not spending as much money on
these things like conference calling is
now free use the grass thousands of
bucks I think for everyone regardless of
what you're working on or doing it's so
important to be as thoughtful as you can
about it and being thoughtful means
thinking about it so throw so many
different lenses from the lens of an
environmentalist or humanist or from the
perspective of someone who is a lower
socioeconomic status or higher
socioeconomic status because everything
you do has an impact and the things that
do the most good for for you and for the
planet for the species like finding that
happy marriage takes a bit of thought
because you don't want to be be the
person who like rushes to develop a
technology that ends up like
annihilating us tipping and there's
plenty of things that we can't predict
but I think just being as thoughtful as
possible and being open to being
corrected and making changes like I do
that that's key I really like how you
finally brought it even back again to
mirror-touch and the idea of empathy and
compassion of what we need across the
planet in order to see people more like
ourselves and I really like the VR
experience that you listed I think
that's a really interesting example of
how we can relate to each other
synesthesia the blending of the senses
neurology all aspects to it from the
firm while you're being formed inside of
somebody all all the way out to when
you're trying to retain cognitive
capacity when you're 80 years old so
there's this incredible journey that
everybody goes on in and our world is
formed in different ways all that we
know is our nervous system right yeah
such a pleasure thank you so much thank
you very much everyone thanks for tuning
in we greatly appreciate it we're here
at the Harvard Medical School campus in
Cambridge we are in Canberra no we're
not Cambridge anymore the medical school
is in Boston Proper it's in Boston but
the university is in Cambridge
universities in can bridge the medical
schools in Boston Proper we are here
right now we are very grateful that it
didn't rain we are grateful that you
tuned in thank you this is
beautiful lawn here at the medical
school campus if you guys had a good
time give us a comment below let us know
your thoughts subscribe join us like the
video share with other people and get
talking get talking about the importance
of all this information
join us on patreon we need your help so
we can continue sustaining this and
growing it and we will see you guys soon
peace
you
you